every team's fan base has that one game
they Circle in a city they've never been
to before Nashville one of the top
choices this year but not if you're a
Raider this trip is all business because
as it turns out the business by all
means could be over with a loss on
Sunday Chris Matthews joins us from
Music City to break it down
there are seven winless teams remaining
in the National Football League two of
them play right here at Nissan Stadium
now the team that drops to Owen three on
their season has about a three percent
chance of reaching the postseason we're
looking forward to the opportunity to go
and spend some quality time together and
just nail down the game plan and get
ourselves ready to go we know this is
going to be a tough game one of these
teams will be seeing a different tune
after Sunday because somebody's o has to
go so one of them will drop to oh and
three and that's pretty much a death
knell to the loser yeah this guy's not
falling and we still Focus you know as
early as on the week too early in the
season it's a long season so you know we
just continue working working to improve
every day another person looking to
improve is Raiders quarterback Derek
Carr in fact he knows very well Titan's
offensive coordinator Todd Downing they
once worked together in Oakland yeah
Derek and I have a great relationship
he's he's a wonderful human being as I
know you guys have seen you know
throughout the years
and Derek is one of those guys that you
know is a perfectionist a pleaser he
wants to try to improve you know at
every turn what you got to figure
Devonte items and Derek Carr will hook
up more than twice in this game as for
the Titans what is going on with their
offense and defense for that matter it's
going to be a big important game here at
Nissan Stadium reporting in Nashville
with the Raiders Chris Matthews eight
Sports now